we've got big breaking news I got this
clip just popped it up on Twitter
January 6 video from Tucker Carlson
shows the police assisting the Q Shaman
as he walks around the Capitol Building
no joke let's play the video they helped
him they acted as his tour guides here's
video of chansley in the Senate chamber
Capitol police officers take him to
multiple entrances and even try to open
locked doors for him we counted at least
nine officers who were within touching
distance of unarmed Jacob chansley not
one of them even tried to slow him down
chancelly understood that Capitol Police
were his allies video shows him giving
thanks for them in a prayer on the floor
of the Senate watch
contrast the reality of what Jacob
chansley did in the Capitol building on
January 6th the India and there it is
right there